und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
das Vertrauen der Deutschen in den Staat
und dessen Handlungsfähigkeiten nimmt ab
nach einer Umfrage halten 3/4 der
deutschen die Verwaltung des Landes für
überfordert das hat eine Studie im
Auftrag des deutschen Beamtenbundes
herausgefunden es herrscht Frust über
Wartezeiten in Bürgerämtern über
schlechtes Management in den Kommunen
und unterversorgte Schulen Frust der
sich immer häufiger in Gewalt gegenüber
Staatsbediensteten ausdrückt mehr als
die Hälfte von Mitarbeitern bei
Ordnungsämtern bei Polizei und
Rettungskräften ist schon beschimpft
oder angegriffen worden das geht so weit
dass Beamte sich inzwischen in
Selbstverteidigung üben kein Witz
Alexander röttig berichtet
messerabwehren Schläge abblocken
wendeten verordnungsdienst der Stadt
Aachen trainiert regelmäßig bei
Ausbilder Volker Haupt es geht rauer zu
auf den Straßen beide haben schon
erschrecken der Erfahrungen gemacht
von kapselanrissen über eine Bisswunde
angespuckt von der infektiösen Person
Beleidigungen und natürlich die Social
Media Sache sind ja die ganze Breite ist
dabei ich habe einmal einen Kollegen
erlebt der selber Nothilfe leisten
musste während einer Kollegin ja fast
erwürgt worden ist und ich kann Ihnen
sagen wenn sie solche Menschen erleben
in der Nachsorge da fließen trennen er
ist vor einigen Tagen Fahrzeugkontrolle
an diesem Kölner Flüchtlingsheim mehrere
Bewohner attackieren die Beamten ein
Polizist der leidet ein Jochbeinbruch
mehr als die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter des
öffentlichen Dienstes haben Gewalt oder
Beleidigungen erlebt so die Studie des
Beamtenbundes bei Polizistinnen und
Polizisten sind es 64% bei
Feuerwehrleuten die Leben retten noch
41% bei Lehrerinnen und Lehrern 37
was tun die bundesinnenministerin
reagiert heute ausweichend will mehr
Strafanzeigen
dafür brauche ich aber Vorgesetzte
dieses mit unterstützen weil diese
Grenze darf nicht verschoben werden die
Menschen dürfen nicht merken wenn sie
sich über Verhalten gegenüber Beamten
dass das einfach so durchgeht sondern
das muss auch Konsequenzen haben doch
gibt es die ein Feuerlöscher fliegt in
der Silvester Nacht auf die
Windschutzscheibe eines Rettungswagens
gezielt geworfen gerade bei solchen
lassen Delikten ermittelt die Polizei
nur selten einzelne Täter und selbst
Rettungskräfte erleben regelmäßig
Angriffe
da kann ich schnell mal passieren dass
eine Flasche fliegt das gehört fast zum
Alltag dazu das kommt vor dass natürlich
beschimpft wird dass auch mal gegen das
Fahrzeug quasi getreten gehämmert wird
während der Behandlung des Türen
aufgerissen werden die Kommunen rüsten
derweil auf auch die Amtsräume im
Aachener Sozialamt zeigt Sachbearbeiter
Thorsten Kretsch die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen Regel Nummer 1
Zutritt nur mit Terminen
das sind die nachgerüsteten Türen also
hier mit Türspion das heißt wir sehen
von innen wer draußen vor der Tür steht
was sehr wichtig ist und wir haben die
panikschlösser das heißt von außen kann
keiner rein es ist abgeschlossen aber
wir können jederzeit wieder raus auch
die Nachbar Büros sind schon als
Fluchtweg eingeplant für den Ernstfall
gibt es einen notfall-code der Kollegen
alarmiert es gab schon eine Geiselnahme
und ein Übergriff auf eine Kollegin
also einmal PC runtergeworfen
Schreibtisch also umgeschmissen
Schranktür aufgerissen und die Kollegen
ist halt auch ja hat das Büro verlassen
musste fliehen
Ordnungskräfte üben Nahkampf Bürgerbüros
brauchen Alarme Anlagen Beamte sind
Repräsentanten des Staates immer mehr
Menschen reagieren an ihnen ihren Frust
ab
was mit einer Gesellschaft passiert wenn
der oberste Repräsentant eines Staates
Misstrauen in die eigene Verwaltung sät
das beobachten wir seit Donald Trump die
politische Bühne der USA betrat Trump
hat bis heute nicht akzeptiert dass er
die Präsidentschaftswahl von 2020
verloren hat er versuchte alles um an
der Macht zu bleiben und das
Wahlergebnis nachträglich zu
manipulieren zum Beispiel indem er den
Landeswahlleiter des US-Bundesstaates
Georgia anrief und ihn an herrschte er
solle gefälligst die fehlenden
11.780 Stimmen finden
dummerweise wurde das Gespräch
mitgeschnitten unter anderem darauf fußt
nun die vierte Anklage gegen Donald
Trump warum sie vielleicht die
wichtigste sein könnte berichtet wissen
es war einmal vor über 30 Jahren da
hatte das FBI den Mafia Boss John Gotti
im Visier und mit ihm sein ganzes
Syndikat das Gesetz das sie hinter
Gitter brachte der Rico Act dient nun
als Grundlage für die Anklage gegen tja
auch sowas wie ein Syndikat
Rechtsberater Mitarbeiter Amtsträger
rund um den mutmaßlichen redelsführer
Donald Trump die Staatsanwältin Fanny
Willis wirft ihnen Wahlbetrug Nötigung
Anstiftung zu Verletzung des Amtszeit
vor
sich kriminell bandenmäßig
zusammengeschlossen um das Ergebnis der
Präsidentschaftswahl in Georgia zu
kippen
in sechs Monaten soll ihr Mammut Prozess
starten gegen Trump und 18 mit
Verschwörer wegen 161 systematischen und
organisierten Straftaten darunter der
anruft Trumps aus dem Weißen Haus bei
dem er den Innenminister Georgias unter
Druck setzte
ich will doch nur
11.780 Stimmen finden
[Musik]
23 Geschworene halten die Anklage für
gerechtfertigt ein Richter prüfte
gestern kurz hier wotum und doch
beschimpft Donald Trump seit Wochen
schon die Staatsanwältin die der
Demokratischen Partei angehört als
rassistisch unfähig und parteiisch die
Anlage sei ein Eingriff in den Wahlkampf
Trumps mit Angeklagter Rudi Giuliani
flankiertste Amtsmissbrauch in der
Geschichte unseres Landes
ich treffe Entscheidungen basierend auf
Fakten und Gesetzen das Gesetz ist
völlig unparteilich so entscheiden wie
er in allen Fällen
das bescheinigt ihr sogar der ehemalige
republikanische Vize Gouverneur von
Georgia Jeff Duncan fordert seine Partei
auf sich von ihrem Angeklagten Expos los
zu sagen
er hat die Moral aus der Partei gesaugt
das ist unsere Chance wenn wir den drei
Magneten Trump Zirkus weiter zulassen
werden wir verlieren verlieren und noch
mal verlieren
[Musik]
am Gerichtsgebäude drückte heute einer
seine Dankbarkeit aus während Trumps
Anwälte behaupten der Prozess Zerstörer
Meinungsfreiheit und Demokratie sehen
andere sein Handeln als Angriff auf
ehrenamtliche Wahlhelfer Wähler und ein
Wahlergebnis das eben nicht gefälscht
war
die normalen Menschen die sich
informieren wählen gehen bei einer ihre
Stimmen durch diese kriminelle
Verschwörung verloren hätten das sind
die wahren Verteidiger der Demokratie
und ich bin froh dass ich jemand für sie
einsetzt
bis zum 25 August müssen die Angeklagten
nun hier antreten die Blumen kamen
übrigens wieder weg natürlich damit
niemand die Neutralität des Gerichts
bezweifelt
und das wollen wir noch einmal mit
unserem Korrespondenten el Matte Wissen
in Washington vertiefen guten Abend
Elmar es setzt ja so ein leichter
Ermüdungseffekt bei der vierten Anklage
ein was unterscheidet diese Anklage von
den anderen
drei Dinge glaube ich also zum einen das
es viel mehr mit Angeklagte gibt als in
den anderen Verfahren das erhöht
natürlich die Chance dass irgendeiner
möglicherweise bereit ist gegen Donald
Trump auszusagen um sich selber zu
schützen das zweite das wird
wahrscheinlich Kameras im Gerichtssaal
geben dadurch kann dann ganz Amerika das
Beweismaterial sehen und möglicherweise
zu dem Schluss kommen es geht hier nicht
wirklich um Meinungsfreiheit sondern um
konkrete Straftaten und das dritte wenn
Donald Trump verurteilt wurde ich sag
mal salopp als Boss einer Verbrecher
Bande dann könnte er sich wenn er wieder
zum Präsidenten gewählt wurde nicht
selbst begnadigen weil es ein
bundesstaatsverfahren und kein
bundesverfahren ist das sind alles
kleine aber sehr feine und wichtige
Unterschiede und trotzdem gibt es ja
immer wieder die These dass all diese
Prozesse Trump am Ende in seinem
Wahlkampf nur nützen werden ist das auch
diesmal so glaubst du
also ich glaube er wird es versuchen
irgendwie Vorteil daraus zu schlagen ein
Beispiel wird wohl den Antrag stellen
dass es alles in ein bundesverfahren
umgewandelt wird weil die Geschworenen
im fulten Landkreis eben in erster Linie
aus einem Pool von vor allen Dingen
demokratisch orientierten Menschen
kommen würden und wenn das abgelehnt
wird dann kann er natürlich sagen seht
ihr dass der Beweis dass dieses
Verfahren unfair ist wird es angenommen
hat der bessere Chancen ich glaube
trotzdem dass mittelfristig ist ihm eher
schadet weil die Beweise eben
offengelegt werden in diesem Verfahren
seine politischen Gegner in der Partei
können Sie als Munition nutzen und die
Wähler müssen sich überlegen ob sie so
einen wirklich als Präsidenten haben
wollen ich glaube dass gerade moderate
Republikaner und auch unabhängige Wähler
davon er abgeschreckt werden wir werden
immer das aus Washington vielen Dank
dorthin
der russische Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine dauert nun schon fast anderthalb
Jahre auch letzte Nacht herrschte wieder
Luftalarm über den gesamten Land in der
Westukraine gab es nach Beschuss mit
Marschflugkörpern Tote und Verletzte wie
viele Menschen in diesem Krieg gestorben
sind lässt sich nur schätzen beide
Seiten halten ihre Verluste geheim um
dem Gegner keine Informationen zu
liefern
UN-Experten haben knapp
9.500 Tote auf ukrainischer Seite
dokumentiert doch diese Bilanz kann
aufgrund fehlender Daten nicht
vollständig sein unsere Reporterin hat
eine Frau begleitet die ihre eigenen
Zahlen hat jeden Tag fährt sie an die
Front um einen gefallenen Soldaten von
dort wegzubringen jeden Tag eine Brühe
berichtet
direkt hinter dem Checkpoint am
Ortseingang von herrson haben wir uns
mit Natalia rodrigress verabredet sie
ist Soldaten auf dem Weg in die
Gerichtsmedizin die Leiche eines
gefallenen Kameraden abholen und nach
Odessa bringen
sie so was
sehr oft manchmal auch täglich
wie schwer ist das
wissen sie der Mensch gewöhnt sich an
alles aber das ist etwas woran man sich
nicht gewöhnen kann
Natalias Job ist gefährlich schon allein
die Fahrt durch die Frontstadt auch
Natalia mit ihrem improvisierten
Leichenwagen ist schon unter Beschuss
geraten
die Russen schießen auch auf tote
Soldaten sie sehen ja sie haben sogar
die Leichenhalle beschossen die Russen
Schießen auf alles Friedhöfe
Leichenhallen zivile Städte
ein weißer Leichensack liegt im
Transporter
Natalia bekommt die Papiere weiß erst
jetzt wen sie die nächsten Stunden bei
sich im Auto hat
er wurde im Jahr 1980 geboren ich hole
es der hijewski ab
eigentlich ist Natalia Juristin Mutter
von drei Kindern als der Krieg ausbrach
hat sie sich freiwillig gemeldet einer
muss diesen Job ja machen sagt sie
wenn du diese Funktion erfüllst die
Gefallenen transportierst wenn du
verstehst dass es deine Waffenbrüder
sind dann verstehst du dass es das
verlorene Leben deines Volkes ist jedes
Leben ist die ganze Welt
jedes Soldaten Begräbnis wird von den
Streitkräften organisiert und bezahlt
wie viele ukrainische Soldaten gefallen
sind dazu gibt es keine offiziellen
Zahlen
das ist der Krieg der Kampf für unsere
Freiheit und die gibt es nie umsonst es
gibt ein ukrainisches Sprichwort gratis
ist nur die Sklaverei sag Blumen
schmuckkreuz alles spricht Natalia mit
den Familien ab Tod und Trauer überall
dabei sind sie sich nach Frieden
ich hoffe so sehr darauf dass dieser
Krieg endet jeder Mensch der hier lebt
hofft dass der Krieg zu Ende geht das
Schlimmste steht Natalia noch bevor die
Begegnung mit den Angehörigen bei der
Beerdigung übermorgen erst dort sagt sie
begreife sie den Verlust
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und einem ganz anderen Thema
nämlich der Pannenserie der
regierungsflugzeuge Außenministerin
baerbock musste ihre Reise in die
Pazifik Region also doch abbrechen und
oder ja und der Airbus wird ausgemustert
künftig sollen neuere A350 für
Langstrecken genutzt werden erklärte ein
Sprecher der Luftwaffe bärburg
inzwischen wieder in Hamburg gelandet
musste ihre Reise zunächst nach
Australien aufgeben nach der zweiten
gleichen Panne die Landeklappen an ihrem
Flieger vom Typ A340 ließen sich erneut
nicht einfahren die Maschine musste
erneut Kerosin ablassen um wieder in Abu
Dhabi landen zu können wer Bock reiste
per Linienflug nach Deutschland zurück
das Auswärtige Amt habe alles versucht
so Werbung der Abbruch sei mehr als
ärgerlich
entwicklungsministerin Schulze dringt
bei ihrer westafrika-reise auf
humanitäre Hilfe für die Menschen in
Niger nach dem militärput hatte die
Bundesregierung die finanzielle
Unterstützung für den Niger gestoppt vor
Beratungen darüber mit der
westafrikanischen Staatengemeinschaft
ECOWAS besuchte Schulze an Mauretaniens
Küste Projekte die auch mit deutsche
Unterstützung die Menschen dort von der
Flucht abhalten sollen indem sie zum
Beispiel vom Fischhandel leben können
in Afghanistan haben die radikale
islamischen Taliban den zweiten
Jahrestag ihrer Machtübernahme gefeiert
Außenministerin bärburg spricht von zwei
Jahren Rückschritt in die Steinzeit
beobachte sehen eine dramatische
Verschlechterung von Wirtschaft
Versorgung und Menschenrechten vor allem
Frauen leiden unter der Abschaffung
ihrer Rechte haben keinen Zugang zu
Beruf und Bildung die Taliban eroberten
Kabul nachdem internationale Truppen
abgezogen waren
unmittelbar vor der für morgen geplanten
kabinettsentscheidung über das
wachstumschancengesetz von
Finanzminister Lindner gibt es offenbar
Vorbehalte in der Regierungskoalition
Familienministerin paulus hat laut
Handelsblatt ein Veto angekündigt das
geplante steuerentlastungsvolumen von
rund 6 Milliarden Euro für Unternehmen
sei ihr zu hoch wenn Lindner zugleich
nicht bereit sei mehr Geld für die
Kinder Grundsicherung bereitzustellen
Menschen mit Behinderungen werden in
Deutschland weiterhin an
gleichberechtigter gesellschaftlicher
Teilhabe gehindert laut einer Studie des
Deutschen Instituts für Menschenrechte
verstößt Deutschland gegen die
Behindertenrechtskonvention der
Vereinten Nationen das soll Ende August
formell überprüft werden die Experten
kritisieren hunderttausende lebten in
Deutschland in einer für sie
geschaffenen Parallelwelt von
Förderschulen
Behindertenwerkstätten oder
Wohneinrichtungen Inklusion müsse besser
umgesetzt werden
die Platte kommt zurück im Westen als
sozialistischer einheitsbau verhöhnt
stand sie in Ostdeutschland zunächst für
Fortschritt immerhin mit Zentralheizung
und fließend warmem Wasser schon damals
in den 70er Jahren war der Plattenbau
das Rezept der DDR gegen Wohnungsnot
vorgefertigte Bauteile in
Massenproduktion zack steht das
Neubauviertel
nun könnte der Plattenbau ein Comeback
erleben serielles bauen heißt das auf
neudeutsch und ermöglicht genau das
schnell und effizient Wohnraum zu
schaffen theoretisch Bundes
hat sich die Platte unter diesem Aspekt
in Halle an der Saale angesehen Andrea
Maurer war dabei
Halle Saale lutherviertel die
bauministerin ist ins vorzeigequartier
gekommen dass vieles hat was Deutschland
fehlt
klimaschonendes günstiges soziales
wohnen ein wohlfühltermin wenn da nicht
das Versprechen wäre dass sie und der
Kanzler dem Land gemacht haben 400.000
neue Wohnungen pro Jahr 400.000 ist der
Maßstab für Klara Geiwitz Erfolg und sie
ist meilenweit davon entfernt die
400.000 das war die errechnete Bedarf
vor drei vier Jahren und ich denke mal
der ist eher gestiegen als gesunken
demzufolge müssen wir auch wenn es
wesentlich schwieriger geworden ist
durch den zündsprung alle anstrengenden
z.B durch seriellen Wohnungsbau und
Unternehmen um schneller und preiswert
zu bauen
serieller Wohnungsbau heißt Gebäude
werden wie in der Autoherstellung in
einem Werk zumindest teilweise
vorgefertigt kann ein neuer Plattenbau
die Lösung sein
als die bauministerin schon längst
wieder aufgebrochen ist fährt
Genossenschaft Guido Schwarzenberg mit
uns noch nach Halle Neustadt sein
Bauverein hat hier auch Teil sanierte
DDR Platte im Bestand
ganz wichtig finde ich aber bei der
Platte und deswegen ist sie tatsächlich
zu Unrecht in Verruf geraten sie ist
nahezu das Klima schonendste und
nachhaltigste was man anbieten kann wir
haben hier relativ kleine Wohnungsgrößen
wir haben hier insgesamt begrenzte
Dimensionen auch was wohnungshöhe und so
weiter betrifft und vielleicht noch ein
ganz wesentlicher Punkt wir sind in
aller Regel hier Fernwärme beheizt also
ganz viel was in der Klimawende noch vor
uns steht ist hier bereits realisiert
worden Anfang Juli war die bauministerin
in Tokio serieller Wohnungsbau hat in
Japan Tradition Clara Gallwitz ist
gekommen um zu schauen was hier möglich
ist und in Deutschland eben nicht
zehn Fertighäuser am Tag kann Japans
größter Hersteller bauen klimaschonend
und modern
einer der Sachen die hier in Japan
klappen ist dass man das ohne
Baugenehmigung machen kann also
innerhalb von drei Monaten wenn das Haus
fertig produziert ist kann es auch
aufgestellt werden solche Formen von
Typengenehmigung wollen wir auch gerne
in Deutschland unterstützen weil das
Herstellen ist das eine der
Genehmigungsprozess in Deutschland ist
natürlich das andere alles könnte
schneller gehen hört die Ministerin auch
in Weißenfels Sachsen-Anhalt die Firma
Schüco fertigtier Standardlösungen für
Türen und Fenster die beim seriellen
bauen gebraucht werden im Weg steht
Deutschlands Föderalismus
die höchsten
Einsparpotenziale zu wecken oder zu
heben ist es halt toll wenn ich an einem
zentralen Standort ganz viele
verschiedene Module bauen kann die ich
dann innerhalb der deutschen Republik
verteilen kann und sie nicht nur
dezentral in jeweils wieder neu zu
errichten und Fabriken bauen muss
warten bis 16 Landesbauordnung geändert
werden kann in der Branche niemand die
Zinsen steigen baulandwirt teurer
bauchstopps nehmen zu das einzige was
schnell helfen würde sagen sie der
Ministerin bei Schüco höre Förderung
Investitionszuschüsse kurz Geld damit
überhaupt noch gebaut werden kann
und auch bei unserem nächsten Thema
spielen Föderalismus und regelwut eine
Rolle die Windenergie soll ausgebaut
werden und zwar richtig bis 2030 sollen
80 Prozent des Stromverbrauchs des
Stromverbrauchs aus Erneuerbaren kommen
der größte Posten dabei der Wind um das
zu schaffen müsste die Bundesregierung
laut Berechnungen der Uni Köln ab jetzt
jeden Tag 5,8 Windräder aufstellen zum
Vergleich im letzten Jahr waren es 1,5
täglich die Gründe dafür sind vielfältig
Lieferschwierigkeiten Abstandsregeln
Naturschutz Lärmschutz auch deshalb
forscht das deutsche Zentrum für Luft
und Raumfahrt in Niedersachsen daran wie
Wind Energieanlagen noch intelligenter
leiser und damit vielleicht auch ein
bisschen populärer werden können Oliver
deuka
Krummendeich in nordniedersachsen
flaches Land Wind ist hier oben
reichlich vorhanden also der richtige
Ort um an Wind Energie zu forschen das
Ziel effizient und Akzeptanz der Anlagen
zu verbessern ja beabsichtigen eine
ganzheitliche Untersuchung der
Windenergie hier zu machen das heißt wir
haben hier eine komplette
Instrumentierung in den Anlagen drin von
Fundament bis hin ja zu den Blattspitzen
sind Sensoren verbaut und können damit
dann die Windenergie als
gesamtkonzert quasi untersuchen auch
wenn es Windräder schon seit langem gibt
der erste Windpark in Deutschland wurde
1987 eröffnet ist es immer noch ein
recht junger Industriezweig so gibt es
immer noch viele offene Fragen die nur
mit Forschung im Originalmaßstab
beantwortet werden können
die Auswirkung der ersten Anlage auf die
zweite Anlage zu erforschen ist deshalb
wichtig weil es im Zusammenhang mit dem
Zubau mit den zunehmenden Zubau und Wind
Energie immer wieder die Situation geben
wird das eine Anlage die andere Anlage
abschattet das für dazu dass die zweite
Anlage die im Windschatten steht zum
einen weniger Energie erzeugt und zum
anderen aber auch Höhe Lasten sieht und
dadurch höher verschlissen wird mehr
Effizienz bei der Wind Energie dringend
notwendig vor allem im dicht besiedelten
Deutschland wo Flächen für Windparks
Mangelware sind wo bis 2030 der Anteil
erneuerbare Energien mindestens 80%
ausmachen soll zurzeit sind es knapp
über
46%. die meiste Energie wird dabei aus
Windkraft gewonnen das wissen auch
Politiker Bund und Land tragen im Kern
die Kosten dieser neuen
Forschungseinrichtung aber ich bin
sicher dass es eine sehr gut angelegte
Investition 58 Millionen Euro wurden
insgesamt in den forschungswindpark
investiert auch die Wirtschaft hat sich
mit rund 2 Millionen beteiligt einer
konnten hat sich hier engagiert als
führender Hersteller in Deutschland um
für die Branche dazu beizutragen
wichtige physikalische Fragen tiefer zu
erkunden und natürlich außen Grundlagen
Erkenntnissen
Innovationen zu stiften jede Menge
zahlen und besser Ergebnisse werden nun
auf der Anlage gesammelt dieser Mast zum
Beispiel liefert meteorologische Daten
alle Informationen sind der
Öffentlichkeit zugänglich ein besonderes
Interesse dürfte daran wohl die
Industrie haben
und bei uns geht es weiter mit den
Nachrichten zunächst auch aus der
wirtschaftsgundula unterbleiben wir bei
den erneuerbaren Energien um den Ausbau
der Solarenergie voranzubringen plant
die Bundesregierung ein ganzes Maßnahmen
Bündel vor allem die Bürokratie soll
abgebaut werden wenn es um Solaranlagen
am Haus oder auf Balkonen geht Frank
Bethmann was genau hat das
Wirtschaftsministerium davor das ist bei
der Frage wie bekommen wir dann noch
mehr Tempo rein auf diesen ganzen
Papierkram gestoßen rund um Anmeldungen
Rechnungslegung und hat gesagt diese
Hürden müssen wir versuchen abzubauen
und so soll morgen in Kabinett einem
Reformpaket verabschiedet werden was
vieles einfacher machen soll unter
anderem sieht der Entwurf vor das
sogenannte
balkonkraftwerke ohne Anmeldung beim
Netzbetreiber laufen können und
beispielsweise auch die Weitergabe
Nutzung von selbst erzeugten Strom in
Mehrfamilienhäusern unkomplizierter wird
nur zwei von 50 Hürden in weiteren
Punkten geht es auch nach oben
Vereinfachung für gewerbliche
Großanlagen oder darum dass auf
landwirtschaftlichen Flächen mehr
Solaranlagen entstehen können und würde
dieses solarpaket die Sache tatsächlich
so vereinfachen dass die Ausbauziele
realistisch erreicht werden können
zumindest hilft Bürokratieabbau in der
Regel dabei dass mehr investiert wird
und das ist ja auch das ganz klare
Kalkül hinter dieser Gesetzesinitiative
die ampelregierung wir haben das eben
schon gehört wir ja den Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien dann in absehbarer
Zeit auf 80% steigern der Bundesverband
Solarwirtschaft klatschte dann heute
auch schon mal kräftig Beifall weniger
begeistert ist der Deutsche
Bauernverband der ist
verfassungsrechtlich für fragwürdig hält
wenn die Landwirte künftig Betreiber von
Solaranlagen auf ihren Grundstücken
erdulden müssen vielen Dank an Frank
Bethmann für all diese Details
auf Hawaii ist die Zahl der Todesopfer
in Folge der verheerenden Brände auf
mindestens 99 gestiegen und der
Gouverneur von Hawaii rechnet damit das
noch sehr viel mehr Opfer gefunden
werden die Suche sei sehr mühsam und
gefährlich und werde noch Tage dauern
weitere Probleme könnte ein für das
Wochenende angekündigte Sturm bringen
etwa
1.300 Menschen gelten weiterhin als
vermisst
nachdem auch heute wieder heftige
Gewitter über Deutschland hinwegzogen
warnt der Deutsche Wetterdienst noch bis
23 Uhr vor starken Gewitter mit heftigem
Starkregen und Hagel in Brandenburg
der teuerste Fußballer der Welt der
Brasilianer Neymar verlässt Paris
Saint-Germain und wechselt nach
Saudi-Arabien der 31-Jährige spielt
künftig für alle Hilal wie der saudische
Club bestätigte die Ablösesumme soll
unter 100 Millionen Euro liegen auch
andere Stars wie Cristiano Ronaldo oder
salomonie Spiele mittlerweile in
Saudi-Arabien zu Fußball WM der Frauen
die ersten Finalteilnehmerinnen stehen
fest die Spanierinnen haben es zum
ersten Mal geschafft mit dem 2:1 Sieg
gegen Schweden die Gegnerinnen werden
morgen entschieden auch das spannend für
die Fans in Spanien die heute lang auf
Tore warten mussten
in Madrid ist die Freude eher verhalten
in Auckland ist sie riesengroß nach
einem Spiel das erst in den letzten zehn
Minuten so richtig Fahrt aufnimmt 80
Minute und die eingewechselte Salma
platziert perfekt 1:0 für Spanien die
Schwedinnen gefordert 88 Minute
blomquest vom VfL Wolfsburg ebenfalls
ein gewechselt mit ganz viel Gefühl das
eins zu eins eine Minute später die
ebererinnen Olga 16 Meter spanien führt
wieder musowicz im Tor sieht etwas
unglücklich aus es ist der Punkt auf sie
nach einer dramatischen Schlussphase
das ist ein historischer Moment wir sind
im Finale und das wollten wir unbedingt
erreichen
2:1 ein glückliches Ende für laboria
Rocher mögliche Gegner für Spanien im WM
Finale Gastgeber Australien oder
Europameister England
und wir empfehlen Ihnen jetzt noch
unsere Reihe 37 Grad unter dem Titel
Geschöpfe wie wir begleitet die
Reportage Menschen die sich mit viel
Herzblut um ausgesetzte Tiere kümmern
und das waren immerhin 80.000 im letzten
Jahr
und wir sagen bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
schönen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend im Schlepptau von tief Bern
sind kräftige Schauer und Gewitter hier
bei Deutschland gezogen und zwar von
Südwest nach Nordost heute Abend und
auch jetzt gab es ganz kräftige Gewitter
was er in den letzten drei Stunden
passiert ist das schauen wir uns genauer
an heute Abend gab es ja schon heftigste
Unwetter in Erfurt und wie Sie hier
sehen gibt es jetzt auch gerade aktuell
wieder in Thüringen neue Gewitter
interessant sind auch die Gewitter die
hier über Berlin und Brandenburg weiter
nordwärts ziehen und auch in Bayern sind
noch Gewitter unterwegs genauso wie in
Baden-Württemberg die werden jetzt aber
alle schwächer also in der Osthälfte
heute Nacht gibt's noch Gewitter im
Westen ist es deutlich ruhiger und die
Nachttemperaturen sinken auf Werte
zwischen 20 Grad in der Lausitz und 12
Grad in der Nordsee und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 21 Grad
auf den Ostfriesischen Inseln und 32
Grad im Breisgau der Tag beginnt erstmal
ganz freundlich aber schon am Vormittag
gibt's die ersten kräftigeren Gewitter
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen
nachmittags dann auch weiter im Westen
an diesem Wetter ändert sich auch am
Donnerstag wenig dann wird es sogar noch
etwas heißer und der gewitterschwerpunkt
verlagert sich etwas Richtung Nordosten
guten Abend